To close, we're going to use Delta Debugging
to do something pretty cool,
namely to give us a full diagnosis on what's happening
when the program fails.
Our diagnosis will look something like this:
First this variable had this value.
This caused this other variable to get this other value.
Then this third variable gets set to this other value.
That is what finally made the program crash.
In other words, what we get is cause-effect chain
throughout the program, which explains how the failure came to be
in all of this automatically.
This cause-effect chain may or may not include the infected values,
but frequently it does.
Even if it does not, it immediately helps you understand
how the failure came to be.
The basic idea is as follows:
If we can change any of these variables
such that the failure no longer occurs,
then we have found a failure cause.
How should we change a variable?
After all, variables can take arbitrary values.
The rule is not to make them use arbitrary values
but to use values from a successful run.
That is, during execution we change variables
from the values found in the failing run
to values found in a successful run.
If we can change a variable value such that the failure goes away,
we do have a failure cause.